so any parent that is listening to this
has probably heard about the Scholastic
or highlights Book Fairs right this is
supposedly you know oh clean
non-political content that is brought
into schools right you see them in every
private school and every Public School
scholastic is as leftist as it gets if
you're calling Prager you curriculum
right wing then Scholastic and
highlights has have fallen off the cliff
of a cliff of leftism take a look at
this one so this is a book that they've
give it Scholastic has given an award to
okay there's a book called Melissa is
supposedly for fifth and sixth grade
literacy classes if you look at the
actual text in there you'll see that
it's probably written for somebody who
can read at the level of third and
fourth grade Melissa is a book about a
boy that has transitioned into being a
girl and you know it basically
celebrates this gender fluidity a
concept that they're trying to push on
our children you want to tell me that
this is not laced with political
propaganda to call prageru curriculum
find anything from prageru kids and tell
me that it's as Extreme as this
left-wing propaganda but you know what
media Outlets are highlighting that that
this type of product is is a complete
extreme left wing so you know parents
are accept upset rightfully so and we
need our own representation in our
schools and that is what prigger you is
effectively doing
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the CEO of prageru Marissa stright
Marissa from California Los Angeles how
are you
it's great to be here
you see how I kind of stuck it to you
because we used to have a lot of dinners
in Los Angeles and now I'm in the Free
State of Florida and I know you're there
and there's no sense in overly rubbing
you over the head with it and yet
and here I am delivering a gift for you
and your kids for a better education in
Florida so there you go you absolutely
are so we covered it we covered it on my
show this week so let's just dive right
into it uh well why don't I let you lay
it out prageru is now going to be part
of the Florida uh curriculum for young
people go from yeah so we we are now a
Florida state approved vendor which
means that teachers can use prageru
TurnKey lesson plans in the classrooms
which really should not be that
controversial because our content is
wholesome and actually represents what
parents hope to see in kids schools and
you know this seems to be a trend where
Florida seems to lead the way in doing
what it is that Americans actually want
and what's good for for kids so yeah
congratulations to all of those in
Florida who now will start seeing
prageru content in their classrooms in
case you needed one more thing for me to
needle you on and moving to Florida
yourself now you literally are creating
content for our children there you go
there you go yeah
um how did this even come to pass I want
to get into some of the specifics of
what types of things will be being
taught and some of the controversy
around it which is mostly nonsensical of
course but how did this even happen
yeah it's actually an amazing story so a
couple of years ago we launched prageru
kids because we realized that America
needs content for children that is
actually educational that actually
teaches them about American history and
Civics and even financial literacy and
so we had originally a
direct-to-consumer market where we we
had an Ott we had our website and
parents would come onto our properties
and download content and show it to
their children well a couple of years
ago we realized that we can create
another Journey for our consumer and
that is actually through the schools and
so you know we spoke to Manny Diaz who
is the education State commissioner we
bumped into him one time and he said oh
my gosh my kids absolutely love prageru
kids we show it at home all the time how
do we bring this service to other
Floridians and we you know we talked we
strategized and we realized that Prager
you can really fill in a vacuum in the
market because you know teachers are not
being given resources that represent
what America wants they don't they are
given resources that are laced with
leftism they're laced with critical race
Theory and while we're winning we have a
lot of Victories we're winning uh School
boards we're willing we're winning
Governors and representatives that do
represent the public that do represent a
patriotic America the problem is that
there isn't enough TurnKey lesson plans
for teachers to actually use and so even
if we have these great victories of
folks sitting on boards or even Finding
Normal teachers that are willing to
teach what should be taught they also
need resources and so prageru is
stepping into this vacuum to produce the
resources that the communities whether
it's the teachers or the parents want
and what's really great I think about
the curriculum that we make or the
content that we make is that the
teachers can use the content but they
can all also provided to the parents to
use at home we call it the flipped
classroom and so if a child is watching
a video at home there is no secrecy they
can watch that video in school and vice
versa right so the teacher can show the
videos and they can say to the parents
if you want to have reinforcement if you
want to know what's happening in the
classroom you can go into the website
and see exactly what's being taught in
school no more gaslighting man I mean
that is completely counter to what is
going on certainly in California and
many other blue States but I like a
phrase you just said they're laced with
leftism because when I heard about this
that you guys were going to be working
with the state of Florida I think I saw
a tweet from prageru about it so then I
did a little Google News search and of
course all the usual hit pieces and
nonsense come out the first one I saw
was from Miami New Times and this is
what we referenced on the show a couple
days ago I just thought I'd read one
paragraph just a couple sentences to you
because it's just so perfect prageru a
conservative non-profit often criticized
for downplaying systemic racism and
promoting anti-immigrant theories
announced today that Florida is quote
the first state to officially approve
prageru as an educational vendor now
it's funny because that doesn't sound
that evil except they are immediately
often criticized for downplaying
systemic racism as if it exists just
because they're saying it and promoting
anti-immigrant theories which I've never
heard on prageru I've heard things about
actually having a border that matters
but nothing about anti-immigrant but
you're used to this sort of thing I
suspect I mean you say often criticized
often criticized by whom the teachers
unions who don't care about our kids and
don't they actually don't even care
about parents right they only care about
their own money and their own power and
so yeah sure the Nea and the afd
criticize us all the time except you
know there's they have had so much power
and influence over America's education
system that now they're criticizing us
because frankly they're scared they know
that we represent the majority of what
Americans want and they have too long
had so much control over our education
system they're calling our content
political our whole point is to actually
bring americanism and Truth to
classrooms while they are using
curriculum I'll give you a couple of
examples of the type of stuff that they
sell God you're not going to show me one
of these naked books that they've got
I'm going to show you here we go so any
parent that is listening to this has
probably heard about the scholar plastic
or highlights Book Fairs right this is
supposedly you know oh clean
non-political content that is brought
into schools right you see them in every
private school and every Public School
scholastic is as leftist as it gets if
you're calling prig or you curriculum
right wing then Scholastic and
highlights has have fallen off the cliff
of a cliff of leftism take a look at
this one so this is a book that they've
give it Scholastic has given an award to
okay there's a book called Melissa is
supposedly for fifth and sixth grade
literacy classes if you look at the
actual text in there you'll see that
it's probably written for somebody who
can read at the level of third and
fourth grade Melissa is a book about a
boy that has transitioned into being a
girl and you know it basically
celebrates this gender fluidity concept
that they're trying to push on our
children you want to tell me that this
is not laced with political propaganda
to call prageru curriculum find anything
from prageru kids and tell me that it's
as Extreme as this left-wing propaganda
but you know what media Outlets are
highlighting that that this type of
product is is a complete extreme left
wing so you know parents are accept
upset rightfully so and we need our own
representation in our schools and that
is what prageru is effectively doing you
want to show me one more of these Lefty
propaganda books
Library there like you gotta really
really try to figure out why America is
teaching you know this kind of stuff but
I I have a whole list for of it and I'm
sure any parent listening has their own
list of this kind of stuff uh you know
the thing is that up until now the
education system of America has been
represented by the teachers unions who
have represented left-wing propaganda
and prageru is representing the parents
of America we are not paid by any sort
of uh political group that is pushing
this kind of you know political roping
of our children and so you know yeah
sure they're upset and because of that
they're gonna lie about us at the end of
the day we're not misleading and
problematic we're actually very
transparent about what we stand for
unlike these other curriculum makers
right so so first up what what ages are
you guys going to be writing curriculum
for working on the curriculum for yeah
so our partnership with Florida actually
starts from kindergarten and so we have
content from kindergarten all the way
through through college with our five
minute videos
wow so and this is all going to be new
stuff old stuff blend blend of the
things that we know of you guys is a
little uh Dave Rubin while I left the
left gonna make it in there absolutely I
mean we're hoping that we'll be in there
look we believe in education choice so
at the end of the day it's up to the
schools to choose what kind of content
they want to use we are providing with
them with the tools so they can be more
successful but at the end of the day if
they stumble upon why I left the left
with Dave Rubin and they realize that
it's something worth bringing into the
schools at least we're protecting the
chi the teachers from being fired from
using those videos and we're providing
them these TurnKey lesson plans that
they can they can use ultimately it's up
to the communities to decide what it is
that they want to use from our you know
vast library of content and the next
steps for us is not just to work with
Florida we're working with Texas we're
working with additional states around
the country you know Florida is taking
the first step because they're brave for
our people but yes you will see a lot
more content and much of it is going
going to Echo some of the state
standards that are already out there and
so if if Florida has State Standards to
teach certain things we're reading
through it and we're developing some of
this content together with um with the
states even though you guys have been in
this for a while and you personally for
a while and you've dealt with the
censorship and the big Tech stuff and
you guys have sued Google and all of
that stuff are you shocked that the way
that the schools have gone about so much
of this meaning not just that they're
pushing these books but the way they
hide it from parents specifically like
there's almost an apparatus in place
it's not just we're going to let you
read this stuff we're also going to let
you read it call you a different name
and not tell the parent that's that's a
whole different level than just dealing
with it at a curriculum level yeah I
mean every single day working in this
field honestly shocks me you know Randy
weing
of the AFT the Amer American Federation
of teachers I don't know if you know
this but she doesn't even have kids
right yes I did not I did not know that
but that might be why she thinks
everyone else's kids are hurting Becky
Pringle Becky Pringle who's the union
boss head of the largest teachers unions
the the Nea she doesn't have kids either
and so that's wild actually you know
it's pretty well everyday shocks we now
Randy Weingarten is working with
President Biden on some task force an
extension of the Department of Homeland
Security and so those of us parents who
are really upset that they put the FBI
on us when we went to school boards and
protested against the lockdowns now
we're even more concerned what is going
on here you have the teachers unions
that own effectively they own the
Department of Education which you
probably already know that this
department needs to be dismantled
because here our taxpayer dollars are
going into funding an organization that
doesn't care about our children on top
of that now you have Randy involved with
Department of Homeland Security on top
of that they're working with News Guard
which I know already got you in trouble
for saying the word newsguard on your
show right but therefore just real quick
for people that don't remember last time
you were on the show maybe like four
months ago you said something about
newsguard on a Friday on the next Monday
I had an email from newsguard in my
inbox saying we are now looking into
your show which then I blew up publicly
and apparently I scared them off but God
only knows what they're working on but
thank you again afraid that you're you
know Dave I was afraid that you actually
won't let me back because you know
attacking teachers
attacking the teachers unions is a scary
thing many many people have said to me
are you sure Marissa that you're willing
to take this on because they are a very
very powerful group and so look look at
my shirt I'm the Mama Bear right that's
what I care about at the end of the day
what am I going to do with my life and
my time if not to protect America's kids
but yes every single day shocked me to
it shocks me when I'm in this field
because how do we have people that have
so much power and so much influence over
our children yet
everybody is afraid to push against them
right yet they are just amassing more
and more power while they're not
bringing any result any positive results
for our kids it is it is pretty shocking
but you know I also think that America
the timing for what we are doing right
now could not be any better I think that
there are many people like Governor
DeSantis and Manny Diaz and and other
states which you know will announce in
the next few weeks are realizing that
the true representation of Americans is
one that actually advocates for children
and students and families and not union
bosses
so since I know you and Noah and your
kids personally and since you're wearing
a shirt that says Mama Bear does it say
mama bear I didn't see bear I said
there's bear on there there is in my
heart oh the Bears in your heart okay oh
that's the point okay got it got it
um can you talk a little bit about like
what it's like to live you live in LA
blue place I've heard you talk about
what it's been like yeah well but I
don't mean it about the crime in the
homeless and the drugs and all that I
mean literally about the kids stuff
we'll stick with that just trying to get
your kids in a place where they will not
be infected by this stuff because it's
great that you guys will hit up Florida
and Texas and some of these other places
but obviously a place like Cali and New
York they're not going to be open to
these ideas and parents there just don't
know what to do yeah you you know I
think it actually for parents who live
in States like California and New York
it's it's even more of a wake-up call
but not the only we're not the only ones
who have to wake up to the issue that
separating the education of our children
uh from our house holds is a bad thing I
mean parents have been taught that our
job is to obey their kids feed them
maybe take them to sports uh make sure
that they get a good night's sleep and
you know rinse and repeat not be that we
have been asked to not be involved in
the education of our kids and if you
live in a place like California you
realize even more so how important it is
that you are involved in the education
of your children if a teacher tells you
that they're not sending homework home
or you don't need to be involved in what
it is that they're learning or if you
feel like you're being gaslit right
which is what many parents are
experiencing by the way not just in
California this is happening also in
Florida and in Nashville right we are
actually we need to be both on alert and
we need to take back the education of
our kids and I'm not saying do not send
your kids to school I understand that
not every parent can homeschool Noah and
I cannot homeschool we do send our kids
to to school but we are very very
involved we ask a lot of questions we're
involved in inoculating them and
educating and talking to them this is
why we've made these short sound bites
these short little vignettes these
videos that you can you know sit around
the dinner table and have these
conversations with your children so that
when they go up to school or to the mall
or they even watch Barbie God forbid
right you know how to have these
conversations with your children and you
know I think that our guard is is up
when you live in a state like the state
that I'm living in but we need to really
set an example for other parents around
the country that all of our guard needs
to be up when it comes to our kids
everywhere and so it's definitely
difficult to raise kids in California
but I think that it reminds us of how
important it is that we we don't you
know forfeit the education of our
children
I saw in some of the articles that were
criticizing you people were saying but
prageru is not accredited they're not
accredited which to me when I hear
someone's not accredited probably doing
something decent uh Jordan Peterson
Academy the Peterson Academy not
accredited I'm pretty sure people are
learning over there and learning with
Prager you but can you talk a little bit
about accreditation and why people
should uh perhaps not be so obsessed by
it right if you think about it actually
the word accredited should be synonymous
with the word controlled right and so
that is what these accreditation
institutions have become they have been
able to really control information and
so if you don't want to be controlled by
you know big government or uh you know
big advertisers I mean remember there
are a lot of advertisers in the world of
Education as well not to mention you
know political agendas if you don't want
the control then you actually may want
to look for institutions that are not
accredited because then you can actually
get truth and and unfiltered and
uncontrolled and that has really been
our motive here at prageru is not
necessarily to be accredited but I'll
let you in on a little secret there is a
state that we are working with right now
and I you know I can't name it yet
because I don't want it to get messed up
where kids can get uh actual school
credit for finishing certain modules
with prageru and so let's take the
example of our financial literacy module
where you can actually acquire a lot of
skills and education through finishing
our financial literacy videos and and
completing the checking for
understanding unit if you finish the
unit and you submit that to your school
the state is actually going to give
School Credit High School Credit to kids
who who do that now it again we're not
an accredited institution but people can
get credit for watching prageru videos
in high school
how do you make sure it doesn't get
political because in in you know I know
you don't want to indoctrinate these
kids you want them to know the truth and
that will certainly be connected to the
to the stuff that you're giving them but
at some point it then leads to political
thoughts obviously so how do you make
sure you don't just become the polar
opposite of what the left is doing right
now
you know I think that when it's the
right time for kids to start talking
about you know these kinds of political
issues then we encourage debate and
essentially what we would say is that
you know sixth or seventh grade listen
to both products right we know that
there's a product called CNN 10 and then
in many schools Across America this is
news provided by CNN in virtually every
classroom across the United States right
there is no debate in our in American
schools right now if you want real
debate then have both and I'm not saying
take CNN 10 out of schools I'm just
saying well if you're watching CNN 10
then also watch the prageru products and
allow the child to listen to both and
you know Foster critical thinking so
that they can ultimately make their own
decisions you see we are not the ones
who are calling to boycotts Scholastic
and CNN 10. I'm not calling for that I'm
calling to have an even playing field in
the mind of of American Kids watch both
have discussions at home make sure that
your parents are involved as well and
then ultimately make your own decisions
but the fact that we are not allowed to
enter America's schools because they
have put a gate in front of our
education system that in my opinion is
political indoctrination and that is
what we're advocating against just allow
us to show up as well so people can make
their own decisions what do you think
the indoctrination is doing to these
kids
um Beyond like the obvious stuff that a
lot of kids now are suddenly can you
know confused about their gender
identity or something I mean as you know
we have two baby boys here and I think
about it every day I'm like man their
their world is so open it is so my
responsibility to fill them up with as
much of the right stuff as possible so
the bad stuff doesn't get in I can't
imagine being a parent of a five year
you know a five-year-old finding out
that your kid suddenly is confused about
all of this stuff like like I mean it's
sort of more socially than educationally
what do you think is happening with kids
right now
I mean you're seeing depression rates at
an all-time high I mean you talk about
five-year-olds and obviously with
five-year-olds or seven-year-olds it's
very difficult when they're you know
sexualized early and Confused early but
by the time they they reach age 15 uh I
mean really it's horrendous it's either
depression body dysphoria the body
dysmorphia you know also kids who don't
have something to stand on actual real
education to stand on that vacuum is
filled up in other ways you know they
the the anxiety is an all-time high kids
don't even know how to date anymore
because there's all of that confusion
and then if you look really Downstream
employers like we have 150 employees
working for prageru and we are getting
the cream of the crop here but talk to
other CEOs what is America's Workforce
look like right now when we have kids
who have been taught from you know
kindergarten through 12th grade and
oftentimes post-grad that uh you know
there are Vic victims that you know the
system is set up against them that you
know they should just do what feels good
to them all the time this stuff is
what's laced this is the leftism that I
think is dangerous that is actually
laced in school curriculum that is what
scares me I don't want my child to be
taught that they're a victim I don't
want my child to be taught that America
is a horrible place to grow up in I mean
that alone creates anxiety right it's
like oh you have no future you're living
in a horrible country all of those kinds
of ideologies that are in our you know
in our classrooms are are frankly scary
and and we do need to find a way to
inoculate our children against
the culture the media the schools that
are teaching our kids how to not be
successful that to me is even more scary
than the fact that they you know can't
do math or can't read properly is is
this you know you know brain mush that
they're experiencing and then you take
math of course and you know they're
hearing that math is racist and you know
I mean
I mean that that really is terrible like
you know you think that Russia and China
and the other countries that we're
competing against are teaching this kind
of garbage to their to their kids no
Tick Tock in China is very different
than Tick Tock in the United States I
should note since you mentioned your uh
150 employees that two of my employees
are former prageru people and they have
done a bang-up job over here which is
obviously indicative of what you guys do
over there and you also gave it the
blessing to allow them to come to me
which does a little something about you
as a CEO we can send these people the
good people to prageru kids if they want
to see some of the stuff that kids in
Florida will be learning yeah go to
prageru what I really recommend uh for
All Families is to download the prageru
app either you know if your kids have an
iPad I'm sure many do or you can
download it onto your smart TV onto onto
your your phone and instead of them
watch you watching YouTube have them
watch prageru and you know you can trust
the content and know that it's wholesome
and safe I know you're not doing toddler
stuff but you know about this Miss
Rachel lady half my day is watching Miss
Rachel now yeah yeah we'll get there
we'll get there we'll do music and
toddler stuff and we'll we'll get there
oh watch out Miss Rachel Marissa it has
been a pleasure as always and we'll link
to everything right down below thank you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell